Hello, I'm Emma Raducanu and I'm here today with Porsche.
The dreams that kept me going back then...
...were to win Grand Slams and to play at Wimbledon.
For me, it's all about continuous improvement and getting better...
...and just trying to learn and experience new things.
I feel like my culture and my family background...
...has definitely played a part...
...in who I am and my personality and character.
I love motorsports because I feel like...
...it's just a drive for continuous improvement...
...and I feel like it's actually quite similar to tennis.
My favorite Porsche car is the 911 for sure...
...because I feel like throughout every generation,...
...it's so unique and so beautiful in its own distinct way,...
...and I feel like it's one of the most iconic cars that are out there.
Porsche has always been in my head.
It's one of the brands that I've always loved from a young age.
For me to be a brand ambassador for Porsche...
...means a lot because I feel like...
...now I might be able to sit on my own 911 one day...